Ellie?
Ellie, hurry up!
We've only got five minutes.
I'll be right down.
I'd like to say a few words
about what's happened
to me over the past year.
You women may not sympathize.
You think men have it easy.
But that's where you're wrong.
Man is a very delicate
and sensitive mechanism.
If you treat him right,
you flatter him
and butter him up a little bit,
he's good for years.
But if somebody
rocks the boat...
Well, you know how it is, men.
You work hard for years,
trying to build a home,
raise a family, and then
comes one wonderful day
when, for the first time
in your life,
you feel you're a little
ahead of the game.
Things have eased up
at the office.
The kids are all set, married
or well along in school or both,
and you're raring to go.
You think of all
the wonderful things
you would have done in your life
if you just had time.
You go fishing.
You go big-game hunting.
You might even climb
Mount Everest.
Anyway, you're on
top of the world.
You begin to feel
you're a combination
of Don Juan and Columbus.
And that's just the moment
they choose to let you have it.
I remember it was
just a year ago today.
I caught my usual
commuter's train.
It was late, as usual.
It was such a beautiful day
that I let the bus go by
and walked home
from the station.
It was one of those
first warm days in May
when everything seems
to come to life.
I felt particularly well.
I was thinking
what a lucky man I was,
with a nice house all paid for,
three children all paid for,
and a beautiful wife.
Ellie.
- Oh, hi, Pa.
- Hi, boys. Hello, Del.
- Mr. Banks.
- Ellie, I'm home!
Coming.
Ellie was radiant that night.
She seemed to be
floating on air.
Stanley, what kept you?
It's late.
Such a nice day, I walked.
Stanley!
What's the matter?
Can't a fella kiss his wife?
Oh, you won't have time
to change.
We have to start right away.
Why? Where are we going?
Kay and Buckley asked us
to their apartment
for dinner tonight.
She phoned this morning,
said she had some good news.
Oh! Oh! Buckley put over
the deal, I guess,
with the chain stores, huh?
That plastic bag of his?
Oh, I don't think
that's their big news.
I think it's something
much more important that that.
More important than that? Why?
That means thousands of dollars.
I don't know. What could be
more important than that?
Something, nothing.
- Get my coat, will you, dear?
- Yeah.
Night, Tommy.
Night, Ben.
Good night, Mom.
Kay said she was sorry
she couldn't have you, too,
but she had to have Buckley's
father and mother.
- Is Kay gonna cook?
- Mm-hmm.
You better take
your bicarb with you.
Oh, no.
- Oh, boys, don't keep Delilah.
- Son, son, your jokes
- get funnier every year.
- Stanley, please!
I promised her
she could go to the movie.
Ben, you drop her on your way
to the game.
Oh, and, uh, Delilah,
stack the dishes until after.
You'll miss the first
of the picture.
- Thanks, Miss Banks.
- Um, Tommy don't study too late.
Remember, if the rug man calls,
tell him to call --
S-Stanley!
What's got into you?
It's spring.
It must be.
Yes, sir, we're in a rut, Ellie.
Not that it isn't
a pleasant rut,
but I think we ought to
get out of it.
You know, you're
a very beautiful woman, Ellie.
Why, Stan.
A very, very beautiful woman.
Trouble is, I never see you.
Come home at night,
you wanna know
if I've seen the hole
in the carpet
or whether I'll fix
the leaky faucet.
I'm sorry.
Oh, I don't mean that
it's your fault. No.
I think we ought
to forgot about it, though.
We ought to forget the house,
forget the whole thing,
go away and take a trip.
No reason why we can't.
We're as free as the air.
Kinda like when we were
first married.
Before Kay came along.
Only this time we're not broke.
We could even go to Europe.
I think we better wait
and hear what Kay has to say.
Honolulu! What about Honolulu?
That's the place.
- How about it, Ellie?
- We'll see.
Oh, sure.
Waikiki beach,
moonlight on Waikiki.
Flowers, ukulele, romance.
Well, I'm gonna call up that
travel agency in the morning,
find out about those trailers.
- Hi, there!
- Hello, darling!
There she was, my Kay,
the darling of my heart.
I couldn't yet believe
she was a married woman.
She still seemed like kid to me
playing at keeping house.
How are you?
You feeling alright?
Feeling alright?!
Look at her. How does she look?
Never looked better in her life.
Oh, thank you, Pops.
- How's he treating you?
- Oh, fine.
- You miss me?
- Hmm, don't talk.
- Hello, hello!
- Buckley dear.
I was full of the milk
of human kindness that night.
I even looked at my son-in-law
with a friendly eye.
I don't say
that he was my ideal,
but I was getting used to him.
Father Banks, how are you?
Nice to see you!
How have you been?
Oh, give me your hat!
Say, uh, do you think
we could kinda do away
with that "Father Banks" stuff?
- Just call me Stanley.
- Okay, Stan.
Alright, not Stan.
Stanley.
- Stanley?
- Yeah.
Okay, Stanley.
How about little golf
on Sunday?
Ah, you're on.
Doris, it's wonderful
to see you again.
Well, Herbert boy, how are you?
Oh, so-so.
So-so?
Why, you look wonderful.
- Doris, how are you?
- How are you?
What's wrong with the old man?
It's the spring.
It always takes it out of him.
Takes it out? Puts it into me,
doesn't it, Ellie?
I suppose you got
the same message we did.
- Very important news.
- Yes, yes.
That's right.
- Kay, I can't wait.
- You have your cocktail.
Oh, darling,
you can't do this to us.
Buckley, you tell us.
We're all here now.
- Thank you, Buckley.
- Hope it's what I hope it is.
I know what it is.
Great news, eh, Buckley?
Well, I-I think it is.
Oh, Buckley did you tell them
and not tell us?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I guessed it.
You really put it over,
didn't you, boy?
Oh, Buckley, he's not right.
It's not that horrid contract.
A contract?
Is that what it is?
Thousands of dollars.
Oh, and we hoped it was a baby.
Oh, I prayed for a baby,
and now to hear this.
But, Mom, that's what it is.
It is a baby!
- A baby!
- What?! A baby?
Oh, Buckley, that's wonderful!
Oh-ho, congratulations!
I'd never seen such excitement.
Kay was passed around
like a loving cup.
I can't tell you
how delighted I am.
Buckley stood by
trying to look modest.
He only succeeded in looking
slightly half-witted.
I grinned and tried to join in,
but somehow there was
a fly in the ointment.
I couldn't put my finger on it,
but there was definitely a fly.
Yes, sir. That's the greatest
news I've had in years.
How about that, Grandpa?
Grandpa!
That was the fly.
Grandpa.
First he steals my daughter.
Now he makes
a grandpa out of me.
I do wish she'd go to Dr. Barns.
After all, he's taken care
of her all her life.
But I suppose this man
is alright, though.
Good gracious, November.
That doesn't give me much time.
And I have a million
things to do.
Ben? Tommy?
- What do you want them for?
- I want to tell 'em.
Ben? Tommy? Wake up.
Tommy, Ben.
Boys, do you hear me?
Something wrong?
What is it?
- What's the matter?
- The most exciting news.
Kay is having a baby.
Right now?
- No, silly, November.
- Poor Buckley.
"Poor Buckley?"
What do you mean, poor Buckley?
You wouldn't say that
if you'd been there tonight.
He was just bursting with pride.
We were standing there telling
him how delighted we were,
and he just stood there
looking sort of cute and shy.
Wasn't he cute, Stanley?
Cutest thing you ever saw.
Oh, alright, alright.
You're all alike, you men.
Good night, Tommy.
Sorry I woke you up.
Now night, Ben.
Go back to your book.
Good night, Ben.
Good night, Tommy.
Um, no need of broadcasting
this, you know.
Mrs. Dickson, please.
Ellie, what are you doing
calling people up
at this time of the night?
Will you please ask her
to call Mrs. Banks
the minute she comes in?
I have some very important
news to tell her.
Mrs. Dickson
would not forgive me
if I didn't tell her right away.
You know, I think
I'll give Kay a baby shower.
We could have it on a Saturday
and you could ask the men
to come in afterwards.
Ellie, do we really have to
blaze this thing
- from the housetops?
- Huh?
You know, after all,
it really isn't our affair.
Stanley, what's
the matter with you?
I swear you act as though
you almost didn't like the idea.
I don't!
Why, Stanley?
For heaven's sake, why?
I'll tell you why, exactly why.
In the first place, they haven't
got room enough for a baby.
The little apartment
they live in
isn't big enough for the two
of them, much less a baby.
Second place,
they can't afford a baby.
Babies cost money.
The older they get,
the more they cost.
What do they think
they're gonna use for money?
You heard him tonight,
didn't you?
When I asked him if he had
the contract, said no,
but did that faze him?
Oh, no, no.
He just stood there
looking cute.
Cute? And he's the one
who's going to be the father.
Well, I'll tell you something.
If he's got any idea
that I'm gonna pay for it,
he's got another thing coming.
I just got through
paying for the wedding.
And another thing --
I think they ought to wait.
Wait? For what?
For seven or eight years,
that's what.
What do they know
about children?
My Kay is just a child herself.
Here she gets out of college,
marries the first guy
she comes in contact with.
Now she's saddled with a baby.
Stanley Banks, you listen to me.
I left school to marry you.
Do you remember that?
And do you remember
when we were married?
Of course you don't.
We were married
on the 4th of September.
What's that
got to do with it?
And do you remember
when Kay was born?
The 21st of June.
Exactly.
While my class was up there
on the platform graduating,
I was home having a baby.
Well, I don't...
Oh, Stanley, I-I-I know
they haven't money
and the apartment is small,
but those things don't
really matter, do they?
The important thing is that
we're going to have
a grandchild.
Darling, it's like
getting a dividend.
It's like getting a dividend?
Yeah, something comes to you and
you don't even lift a finger.
You have none of the
responsibilities of a baby,
none of the hardships.
All you have to do is love it.
Hello? Ruth? I have the most
marvelous news for you.
I am going to be a grandmother.
- "It's like getting a dividend."
- Yes! Isn't that divine?
Oh, we're so excited!
Yes, Kay told us about it
tonight.
Ellie didn't seem
to mind the idea.
Maybe women were different, but
when I thought a grandfather...
Why, I was the guy
who was going places.
The whole world of adventure
was waiting,
just waiting for me
to give it the nod.
And now a grandfather.
I thought of the other
grandfathers I knew.
Why, they were old, old men.
The toothless old codger
down the street.
That client of ours
whose only fun
was cutting people
out of his will.
Those ancient dodos
at the club.
You'd have to use a stethoscope
to be sure
they were still living.
I didn't belong with them.
I wasn't ready
for the mothballs yet.
Why, I hadn't even
begun to live.
Only trouble with me was, I
was a little out of condition.
I spent the next afternoon
in the gym.
Oh, that's fine.
Fine, thank you.
- Thank you.
That evening
I felt like a million.
But the next morning,
I felt closer to 100.
Oh!
Oh.
Stanley, Buckley's here
for your golf match.
- Oh!
- What's the matter?
What have you done?
Oh, oh, oh, nothing.
Here, here, here,
let me help you.
- Oh, no, no.
- Where's the pain?
It's -- It's all over.
Oh, whatever did you do?
What happened?
I'll call Dr. Barns and get him
over here right away.
No, I don't want any doctor.
Stanley, for all we know,
it might be your appendix.
If -- How could --
I haven't got an appendix,
and you know it.
- Well, I'll get Buckley.
- Buckley?
If I don't want a doctor,
I certainly don't want Buckley.
Well, I thought
he might be able to help.
Help? Don't you think
he's done enough?
All I want is a hot bath
with some Epsom salts.
Alright, I'll tell Buckley
and be right back.
Oh, Buckley!
Buckley. Oh, oh, oh.
The next week Ellie gave what
she called a "stork shower."
This is one form
of highway robbery
not punishable by law.
Kay! Kay, here's one here
you haven't opened.
Delilah, be sure
to keep all the cards.
Yes, Miss Banks.
Stanley?
Stanley, how wonderful
that you got home in time.
You should see
the things they gave Kay.
Everyone was so sweet.
They all brought her something.
What else could they do, honey?
Oh, Stanley,
you make it sound so sordid.
- Go on in. Kay's in there.
- Oh, no, no, no, no.
That's no place for a man.
Hi, Pops!
Where you going?
Don't you wanna come in
and see my plunder?
- Well, I-I'll see it later.
- Oh, come on.
Stanley, when you're finished,
I have something very important
I wanna talk over with you.
- I'll be in the kitchen.
- Alright.
You just got to see.
The cutest things
I've ever seen.
Well, fine.
Now, I have to go now.
Oh, no, no, go over
and talk to Buckley.
He's just all by himself
over there.
Buckley looked like
a man going down
for the third and last time.
But I decided to let him
stew in his own juice.
I have to talk to Ellie.
Well, what do you want, Ma?
Alright.
I, uh, wanted to talk to you
before the Dunstans got here.
You know how worried I've been
about how we're gonna
rattle around in this house
after Ben leaves
for school in the fall.
Mm-hmm.
Well, I had
a wonderful idea today.
Uh-huh.
I say we ask Kay and Buckley
to move in with us.
Ellie, are you crazy?
Stanley, it'd be so simple.
We could make a sitting room for
them out of Kay's old bedroom
and knock through a door
to Ben's room,
and that could be their bedroom.
Then if we put Tommy
in the spare room,
we could put connecting doors
from the bathroom,
and that would be the nursery
right next to our room.
We could even knock through
a door to our room
so if the baby cr--
Yes, that will be
getting nowhere, Ellie.
No.
Stanley, it won't cost much.
I had the contractor
over here today.
It's a perfect place
for the baby,
and the wonderful thing
would be that
if they wanted to go out
some evening
or even go away
for a week or two,
they wouldn't have to worry.
We'd be right here
to take care of it.
Now, look, Ellie.
I know how anxious you've been
to get your hooks
into that baby.
But the answer is no.
I've been all
through that, you know.
The 2:00 feedings
and the colic and the measles
and all the rest of it, and I'm
not going through it again,
especially with
somebody else's baby.
But it wouldn't be
like that, Stanley.
It would be fun
to have a baby here.
Yeah, you can go over and see
the baby at their apartment
when they get it all
washed and ironed,
but it's not coming here,
and that's final.
Well, you know that apartment
isn't big enough.
Alright, tell them
to buy a house.
They can't afford a house.
They should have thought
of that before.
I don't understand
how you can be so hard
on a poor innocent little baby.
Mom, Pops,
the Dunstans are here.
Would you please come out
and talk to them?
I gotta say goodbye
to the girls.
Of course.
Come on, Stanley.
Doris, Herbert, we were afraid
you weren't coming.
Well, well, Ellie.
Hello, Doris.
And how's Grandpa Banks?
Why? What's the matter?
Well, I'm a little stiff.
I've been taking some exercise.
Exercise?
Well, you're crazy.
Look at me, fit as fiddle.
I always say
the only exercise I get
is burying the men that take it.
Really, this baby's
the best thing
that ever happened to Herbert.
It's given him
a new lease on life.
- Sit down. I'll have Delilah --
- Oh, no, no, no, not now.
You sit down, Ellie.
You sit down.
Ooh, I beg your pardon, dear,
because I've got
something I wanna show you.
Kay, Buckley, come here.
I want you to see your present.
Here, take this out
of the way, will you, Stan?
Now, we're gonna
need lot of room.
Here you are, old boy.
- What is it?
- It's a blueprint!
Here, hand me that chair.
A blueprint for the future.
A blueprint for happiness.
Here now, Stan, just hold
that side down, will you?
And you hold
the other side, Ellie.
There now, you two kids,
take a look at that.
What is it?
- It's your new home.
- Home?
- What do you mean?
- Well, I'll tell you.
I was looking over our house
just the other day.
And it came to me
like an inspiration.
That whole west wing, it was
the perfect place for you kids.
So I called up my architect
and I had him come right out.
Here, let me show you.
Your own study, your own
living room, dining alcove,
kitchen and laundry,
and over here,
baby's room, nurse's room,
and master bedroom.
And it's all plenty commodious.
Ellie was fit to be tied.
She saw that baby
slipping out of her hands.
The living room is 26x22.
Is that big enough?
And best of all, you'll have
two babysitters ready made.
That's right.
Well, kids, how about it?
Why, it's wonderful,
isn't it, Buckley?
Yeah, yeah. Gee, Dad,
that's swell of you.
I'll get that tea now.
Now you understand, of course,
that there's nothing final
about these particular plans.
I just thought I'd give you
a general idea
of what it might look like.
Now, if you'd like
to have your entrance here,
well that can be managed.
I'll call up the architect...
- What's the matter, Ellie?
- It's all your fault.
It never would --
would have happened
if you'd let me ask them here.
Ellie, I don't get it.
You're more excited
about this baby
than you were about any of ours.
Well, you don't understand.
This is the time
that Kay needs me the most.
I was -- I was gonna take
so much off her shoulders.
I was gonna help her
with the shopping
and help fix the baby clothes
and fix the nursery.
Alright, alright, Ellie, if
it means so much, have it here.
- I don't care.
- Oh, it's too late now.
They're going to the Dunstans'.
We'll never see them.
Oh, Ellie, don't be silly now.
You heard what
Doris Dunstan said.
This baby was the best thing
in the world
that ever happened to Herbert.
To Herbert!
They're gonna take over
that baby body and soul.
- Ellie, this is ridiculous.
- Don't talk to me.
You're acting like --
It was so sweet of you.
So wonderful.
And we'll never be able
to thank you enough,
but i-it's really better
this way.
We'd -- We'd only have gotten
in your way.
I'm sorry you went to all
this trouble and expense, Dad.
We should have told you sooner.
Have you already bought it?
Well, practically.
We made a deposit on Sunday.
- I see.
- What's this, Kay?
You got a house?
I didn't realize that you
were in a position to buy.
Well, yeah, we got
a mortgage from the bank.
A mortgage?!
What's wrong with a mortgage?
I had a mortgage myself
until a few years ago.
Tell me all about
the house, Kay.
- Where is it?
- It's in the new development.
It's just darling,
isn't it, Buckley?
It's just big enough for me
to take care of easily,
and there's a nice backyard
for the baby,
and Bob and Bliss
are gonna buy out there.
- Is it furnished?
- Well, uh, no, it isn't.
But we thought we could buy
some unpainted furniture.
Oh, you can't lift a finger.
You don't have to do a thing.
I'll do the whole business.
What's a mother for?
I'd like to know.
Ellie was off again.
For the next few weeks,
I'd stop at the new house
to pick up Ellie.
She was working time
and overtime.
Hi, Pops.
Hi, kitten.
Well, how are ya?
Wonderful. Come on in
and see what we're doing.
Oh, no, you don't.
You stay out in the air.
- I'm alright now.
- What's the matter?
Oh, it was just
the smell of the paint.
Well, it still smells.
Stanley, make her stay out here
while Buckley comes to get her.
He ought to be here any minute.
Let's sit in the shade.
I feel so guilty.
Mom's doing so much.
Oh, nonsense. You know that's
the breath of life for her.
Where do we sit?
How about over here?
There?
How do you like the house, Pops?
- Oh, I think it's just right.
- Doris just loved it.
They said they never
would have moved
if it hadn't gotten
too small for them.
Hmm.
Oh, that must be little Bobby's.
I'll send it to him.
Pops, how did you feel
when you had your first baby?
Did it make any difference
between you and Moms?
I-I mean how did you feel?
Well, I felt fine.
I mean, really?
Well, I felt alright.
Well, I guess my nose was
a little out of joint at first.
I'd been high man with
your mother for over a year,
and then suddenly you came along
and took the spotlight.
You must have hated me.
No, no, I don't think
it was that bad.
I think the worst time
was the first night
we took you home, you know.
Yeah, I remember
we got you home,
gave you your 6:00 feeding,
got you bedded down.
Then we must have gone
to your room a dozen times
the next hour
to see how you were.
Of course, if you were quiet, we
went in to see if you were dead.
And if you cried, we went in
to see what was wrong with you.
I remember lying awake
that night thinking to myself,
"Now, what have we got into?
Here we were,
two perfectly happy people,
free as the air.
Now we're trapped.
Trapped by 20 inches
of screaming humanity."
Do all fathers feel that way?
I only know about myself.
I remember that morning
you -- you woke with the dawn...
...screaming your head off.
And your mother went in
to heat your formula,
and I went in to see what
I could do about quieting you.
And I stuck a finger at you,
and you grabbed it.
Grabbed it with such a grip.
From that moment on,
you had me hooked.
Oh, I hope Buckley
gets over there quickly.
You have to butter him up
a little, you know.
Make him think he's still
part of the family.
Thanks, Pops.
Oh, there he is.
Hi, honey.
- Hi, honey.
- How are you, darling? Ahh!
- Oh, hello, there! How are ya?
- Fine, thank you.
Well, what new wonders
did we accomplish today?
You're gonna see it tomorrow.
Take her along now.
- You'll be late for the party.
- Mom, Buckley can help.
There's nothing left to do.
Your father and I will lock up.
- Have fun.
- Well, okay.
- Goodbye. Goodbye, Stanley.
- Where you going?
Stan, come here.
I want to show you.
How do you like this green?
Isn't it a perfectly
wonderful shade?
- We're gonna use it in here.
- Fine.
And in the hall and every place.
It'll make the house
look much larger.
And the same thing
with the curtain.
I got the most wonderful
bargain today.
A Millen, look at that.
For all the windows.
And this is for the bedroom.
Just wait till you see
the price.
You'll be very proud of me.
I'm staying right
within their budget.
I'm having a marvelous time.
There's only one thing wrong.
I haven't done a thing
about the nursery.
I could cry about it.
What's the matter?
- Herbert's doing it.
- Dunstan?
He was so upset about
their not moving in with him.
He said the least they could do
would be to let him
furnish the nursery.
He's going to give them
a crib and a bassinet
and a screen
and a chest of drawers.
It'll probably all be done
in 14-karat gold.
What are we gonna give the baby?
Stan!
What are you so surprised about?
Didn't you think I was gonna
give the baby a present?
Well, as a matter of fact,
there was something
I was looking at today that
would make a wonderful present.
You put it right in this window,
and it keeps the air clean
and the right temperature.
It's very pretty
and modern-looking.
- It's quite expensive.
- What's the name of it?
I don't know the name of it, but
it will only extend this far.
- Where did you see it?
- Downtown.
You see, uh,
you regulate it from here.
It controls the air and the
temperature at all times, see.
No dust, no soot, no pollen.
- Hmm.
- Wonderful. Ellie's idea.
Wish we'd had one for Tommy.
He probably wouldn't
have those adenoids.
It is wonderful.
And look over here.
Come here.
I want to show you this.
Now, you see?
You turn it on and leave it here
beside his crib.
And then you can go out
and close the door.
And if he cries
or even if there's any change
in his breathing,
you can hear it
from anywhere in the house.
No. Hmm, well, they're
certainly gonna love that.
And here's his combination
bath and dressing table.
Right, just the right size.
What is that?
Oh, that's mine. I thought he
might as well get used to it.
He'll going there someday.
- Oh, he will?
- Oh, yes.
As a matter of fact,
I've already registered him
in the class of 1973.
Mm.
I'm a Dartmouth man myself.
Oh, that's a good college, too.
Now, this bath, Stan, I want you
to notice the height of it.
A good college?
We beat you in football in 1947,
1948, and 1949.
And we shall probably --
And we have defeated you
five years running in hockey.
And our bobsled team
is probably the finest
that has ever been developed
in the history of the world.
Ellie's make some fresh coffee.
A good --
That's one of the funniest
remarks you've ever made.
Now, now, wait a minute.
No, no, now listen here, Stan.
And, you know, scholastically...
Well, what do you think
of our little nursery?
- Isn't it lovely?
- Fine, fine.
The wonderful thing is, most
of it can grow up with him.
The shelves, for instance.
It'll hold his toys now,
but later he can use it
for his tennis racket.
Ellie was right.
They had taken over the baby
lock, stock, and barrel.
- ...and things.
- Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
Oh, thank you, dear.
Isn't that a beautiful
record, Pops?
Mm-hmm.
Mother Dunstan gave it to me.
She gave me the whole album.
I remember that I used to
listen to classical music
while I was waiting for Buckley.
I think that's why
he whistles so well.
Have you ever heard him whistle?
No, no, I haven't.
Well, you should
ask him sometime.
Yes, I will.
I certainly will.
By the way, son,
what are you going to call
this baby of yours?
We've had some terrible
arguments about it.
Haven't we, Buckley?
We've gone through
all the telephone books,
the dictionaries,
the baby books.
Finally, we found a couple
of names we both liked.
Come on, sit down here.
Sit down.
Uh, if it's a boy, we thought
we might call him Andrew.
Andrew? Who's Andrew?
Well, there's a Andrew Jackson
and Andrew Nordell, my doctor.
And besides, we like
the name Andrew.
And -- And we both like
the name Jonathan.
Oh, no, not Jonathan.
Better call him plain John.
Well, we also thought
we might call him Michael.
That's a good name.
Oh, you can't call him Michael.
I went to school with a Michael,
and he smelled.
Well, now, Ellie, just because
your Michael smelled,
you know, it doesn't mean that
all Michaels have to smell.
You know a name that I've loved
ever since I first read
"Little Women"?
Lauren, Laurie.
Remember how dear he was?
How about Timothy?
I think that has everything.
Do you like the name
of Timothy, Kay?
Well, I --
Now, Ellie,
they've already told you
they've been all through this.
Why do we suggest
any more names?
Besides, the names
they have are wonderful.
Jonathan, Michael, Andrew,
they're all wonderful names.
But you have to think
of two names that go together.
Andrew Dunstan, that doesn't
sound very good, does it?
Stanley, they haven't
made up their minds.
They need our help.
If I may interrupt, I think
you're going about this
all wrong.
My idea would be
to use a family name.
Well, that's right.
The first grandson is always
supposed to have the name
of the paternal grandfather,
isn't it?
No, no, no. Now, Doris,
that's not what I meant.
I was thinking of
my great-grandfather Malcolm
or, we", say Uncle Wilfred.
Well, if we're talking
about family names,
what about Stanley?
Stanley Dunstan, that ought
to satisfy everybody.
Well, we did think about that.
No, no, no, no.
No, one Stanley
in the family is enough.
You're right.
Now, how about Cornelius?
That's a family name.
And then let's see.
There's Gregory and Dexter
and David.
I had some wonderful names
in my family, too.
Milo and Fennington.
Fennington, now, that's nice.
That'd be a nice name.
Fennington.
We're all talking
about boys' names.
What if it's a girl?
We've got to decide
on a girl's name.
Oh, it won't be a girl.
Don't worry.
The Dunstans always run to boys.
I'm not worried.
I want it to be a girl.
I like girls.
Where are you going, darling?
I thought I'd wash the dishes.
Oh, nothing of the sort.
I'll do them.
Mom, please let me go.
You do too much, Kay.
You must rest more.
Oh, I don't agree with you.
I think some work
is good for you.
I think she should have a maid.
I'd be perfectly willing --
Of course, I don't mean
she should work if she's tired.
It's this young doctor of hers.
I've always said she should
have gone to our family doctor.
We wanted her to go
to our doctor, too.
There's nothing the matter
with my doctor.
He's fine.
He's wonderful.
He told me not to pay
any attention to --
N-Nobody seems to realize
this is my baby.
Mine and Buckley's.
You seem to think
with the way you talk --
Well -- Well,
I'll have you know this.
I'm going to have my baby
the way I want to.
Well, now that we've succeeded
in reducing her to hysterics,
what do you say we get out
of here and go home?
Oh, she's just high-strung.
- Where are your things?
- In the bedroom.
I'll get them.
Come here.
Oh, thanks.
Pops.
Uh, we're going to
run along, kitten.
Please come in, Pops.
Go ahead.
I'll take their things.
- Aww.
- Oh, Pops, that was horrible.
I was terrible.
They'll never forgive me.
No, no, we -- we deserve
much worse than that.
It wasn't you.
You never interfere, but --
but the others.
Mother and Father Dunstan
and Moms.
I'm doing too much.
I'm doing too little.
She wants a girl.
They want a boy.
No matter what the baby is,
somebody's going to be
disappointed.
Yeah, I think what you'll have
to do is have, you know, twins,
one of each sex.
Thank heavens for you, Pops.
You're the only one
with any sense.
Oh, no, no, I'm just as bad
as the rest of them.
But I'll tell you this.
There's going to be
no more of it.
It'll never happen again.
We'll never gang up
on you again.
Believe me.
- Thanks, Pops.
- You relax, kitten.
From now on,
it's going to be your way.
A-And you won't let them
make a fuss
with Dr. Nordell, will you?
What do you mean, dear?
Well, the Dunstans said
they were going down
to have a talk with him.
Oh, Pops, you won't
let them do that, will you?
Oh, of course I won't.
What nonsense.
He's your doctor.
You have confidence in him,
faith in him.
No one has a right
to destroy that confidence.
Thanks, Pops.
It -- It isn't their fault,
really.
It's just that, well, I guess
they just don't understand
the new way of looking
at things.
Well, after all,
as Dr. Nordell says,
birth is a perfectly
natural thing,
a-a-a glorious thing
and want to be
conscious every minute
so -- so they don't miss
a second of it.
He believes that a woman
should be aware
of the wonderful thing
that's happening to her.
And another thing.
He doesn't believe that
a woman should be separated
from her baby for one second
after it's born.
You -- You should carry it
with you right back to your room
and -- and keep it there
with you,
sleeping right there with you
in your hospital room.
That is a little new, isn't it?
Oh, Pops, that's not new.
Primitive woman
has always done it.
Dr. Nordell was in the Pacific,
and he said the women there,
why --
why, they were never
separated from their babies.
They -- They kept them slung
on their backs
for the first two years
of their lives.
And he said it was wonderful
for the babies.
He said if he had his way, all
of his mothers would do that.
You'd -- You'd carry them
on your back
while you were doing
your housework,
and then when it got hungry,
you'd swing it around
and feed it and then
swing it back again.
He says it gives the baby a
wonderful feeling of security.
Hmm, uh, darling,
you're -- you're, you know --
you're sure that this doctor --
Oh, Pops, you're not
going to start that, too?
No, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Dr. Nordell is wonderful.
- He's marvelous. He's --
- Yeah.
Well, he's simply
terribly wonderful.
Darling, I'm sure he is.
I'm sure he is.
- Kitten, I'm sure.
- Thank you, Pops.
Now, you -- you just go to sleep
and relax.
Okay.
Good night, Pops.
- Good night, darling.
- Good night.
Dr. Nordell will be
with you in a minute.
- Please be seated.
- Thank you.
I just don't like the idea.
I thought we said last night,
the Dunstans and all of us,
that we weren't going to
interfere any more
in their affairs.
I'm not going to have
my daughter walking around
for two years
with her papoose on her back.
Darling, I tell you,
that's figurative.
He didn't mean that literally.
Hmm, just want to be sure.
- Good morning.
- Good morning,
-I am so glad you came.
Now I've met the whole family.
Mr. and Mrs. Dunstan Sr.
were in this morning.
- Oh, they were?
- They were a little anxious.
Thought Kay was doing too much.
But I think I convinced them
that she was alright.
That's a wonderful
daughter you have.
- Thank you.
- Oh, excuse me.
- Won't you, Mrs. Banks?
- Thank you.
So, what can I do for you?
Well, as a matter of fact,
my wife has been
a little worried, too.
And you know how mothers are
at this time.
Only daughter
and all that sort of thing.
I thought the best thing to do
would be to bring her down here
and let her have
a talk with you.
I think that's very sensible.
What particularly
worries you, Mrs. Banks?
Well, actually, I --
Well, actually, it's
the whole thing, isn't it?
Uh, I mean, about it all being
so natural and everything.
I'm just trying to take away
any fear she might have.
You know, the fear of pain
can really produce pain.
But if she understands
the whole process,
if she has confidence in me,
if she knows that I'm going to
be right there with her
to help her when she wants help,
if she trusts me, that's
half the battle, isn't it?
Yes, it is.
And then afterward, having
the baby in the room with her,
I'm trying
to persuade my mothers
to go back to caring
for their babies themselves,
feeding them themselves,
bathing them,
being close to them
instead of handing them
over to some nurse.
I know that this is a lot
to ask of your daughter.
It's -- It's a full-time job.
But believe me,
the rewards will be great
not only for the baby,
but for Kay.
There you are, Ellie.
I told you, all of your worry
for nothing.
It's a --
Thank you, Doctor.
You were nice to give her
so much of your time.
It's to my advantage.
If I have you with me,
then, believe me,
everything's going to be
that much easier.
Well, you certainly
have us with you.
Thank you very much, Doctor.
- You can count on that.
- Very happy to have seen you.
Come on now, Ellie, dear.
The doctor's busy.
Good bye.
For the next month or two,
everything was peaceful.
Too peaceful.
I should have known it was
the calm before a storm.
Ellie, answer --
Telephone, Ellie.
Hello?
Hello -- Buckley?
What?
Buckley, you know
what time it is?
It's a quarter of 3:00.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize.
Is Kay there?
Kay?
Why, of course she isn't here.
What would she --
Hello! Hello?
Buckley, I'll --
I'll take this downstairs.
Hang on.
Hello.
Now, what do you mean,
is she here?
I thought if she were there,
I could come and pick her up,
if she were there.
When did she leave?
What time did she leave?
I don't know.
I-I've been out for a few hours.
I just got back
a little while ago.
What was it?
A fight?
Did you have a fight?
Well, we had an argument, yes.
Look, if anything happens
to her, I'll kill myself.
Don't worry.
I'll do it for you.
Did you look --
Did she take anything with her?
A bag or anything?
She took her hat box
and her umbrella
and her toilet case
and her toothbrush.
Oh, we", don't worry
about it, then.
If she took a toothbrush,
she's not headed for the river.
Uh, did you call up and try
anybody else on the phone?
Well, you might do that.
Alright, I'll be right over.
- Any word?
- No.
- Did you call her friends?
- Everyone I could think of.
The hotels,
and I can't wait any longer.
- I'm going to call the police.
- No, no, no, wait a minute.
No, don't do that yet.
Maybe we can
figure this thing out.
- Uh, did she take the car?
- No.
Is there a bus runs by
at this hour?
Anybody you could think of
might have picked her up?
- I've covered the field.
- Well, then it must be a cab.
- What's the number?
- Fairview 6 --
Fairview 6-1-0-9-8.
But there's no use asking them.
They told me they don't
give out that information
except to the police.
Fairview 6-1-0-9-8.
They said they had to
make it a blanket rule.
There are too many wives wanting
to leave their husbands.
- She have much cash?
- I don't believe so.
I give her money,
but she keeps losing it.
Is this the first time
she's left you?
What do you mean by that?
Oh, come, come, come, my boy.
I'm married, too.
Now, has she ever done
anything like this before?
No. No, she locked me out
a few times, but that's all.
Hello.
Hello, the Green Cab Company?
I know this is
against your rules,
but I-I certainly
would appreciate it
if you could help me out.
Uh, did you get a call last
night from 324 Adam Street?
Look, I told you once,
it's against rules.
Well, I'm not her husband,
you see, I'm her father.
And, uh, she's --
Well, she's, uh --
She's expecting, uh, you know,
and you know how they are
in that condition.
Sometimes they do --
If you could find it
in your heart to help me,
I certainly would appreciate it.
Well...
...there was a call.
Where did you take her?
Thanks, thanks very, very much.
We won't forget this.
Where'd she go?
- Home.
- Home?
Home? What do you mean, home?
This is her home.
Oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I mean my home. Come on.
I'll wait here.
Do you want her to come back
or don't you?
Yes.
Well, then you'll have to
go and get her.
That's the first law
of marriage.
You can't expect
any self-respecting wife
to come home
under her own power.
I don't suppose you want to tell
me what the quarrel was about?
If you don't mind,
I'd rather not talk about it.
Okay.
I don't know whether
you know it,
but your daughter's
got a terrible temper.
I'm sorry.
And this business tonight,
why, it's like a child,
and a spoiled child at that.
She's got to grow up.
She's got to be made to realize
that she can't go
running home to you
every time there's something
that she doesn't like.
Well, what do you want me to do?
Pack up and move?
-Hi, Pops.
Forgot your key, I suppose.
Why didn't you ring?
Oh.
I didn't want to wake up
you and Moms.
Anyway, I --
Doctor told me to sleep
with plenty of fresh air.
Well, you certainly had your
share for tonight, I guess.
Come on.
First, I-I want you
to know this, Pops.
I've left Buckley.
I've left him for good.
I wish you'd tell Moms for me.
Ask her not to fuss.
It's no use.
It's over for good now.
I'd rather not
have to talk about it.
Alright, kitten, it'll be
however you want it.
You know that.
Come on, I'll have your room
ready for you in a jiffy.
Oh, Pops, why did it
have to end like this?
Everything was
so wonderful at first.
I felt fine.
Everybody was so sweet to me.
It takes too long, that's all.
Drags on too long.
I'm ugly now.
I'm clumsy.
Oh, darling.
Darling, don't say that.
Don't you know that
you have a beauty now
that you never had before?
I know what I look like.
I'm dull and stupid.
I can't do any
of the things I used to do.
Now when I need him most,
I've lost him.
Doesn't love me anymore.
Oh, kitten, you mustn't
think things like that.
He loves you more than ever.
He's frantic with worry.
Well, he just said to me
if anything happened to you,
he'd kill himself.
What do you mean?
Did he call you?
He's right out there now.
Oh!
I suppose he told you
everything.
Didn't tell me anything.
Just that you had an argument.
An argument?
That's wonderful.
Do you know what it really is?
There's someone else, Pops.
He's found someone else.
He goes off
and leaves me every night
and tells me he goes to
the office, but it isn't true.
I've called the office,
and he isn't there.
He's in love with someone else.
Oh, darling, don't, don't.
Please, don't, don't.
We'll talk about it tomorrow.
You've got to get your rest now.
I'll -- I'll send him away.
I'll send him away.
She's here.
She's been asleep.
I wouldn't try to talk
to her if I were you
in the mood she's in now.
Did she say why we had a fight?
Yes.
Well, look, I'd like to say
something, just for the record.
It's not true.
Not a word of it.
I've been working every night.
After all,
we're going to have a baby.
You know,
I-I want to give him --
She said that she phoned me
twice there, nobody answered.
Believe me, it must have been
just a few minutes
I stepped out
for a cup of coffee.
I told her this again and again.
She won't believe me.
Well, you ought to
have more sense
than to argue with her
at a time like this.
You know she isn't herself.
Well, I'm not myself, either.
Look, I even thought of having
a man call Kay and tell her --
Then I said to myself,
"She doesn't believe me.
She doesn't believe me
that I'm working like crazy
night after night
for her and the baby.
She doesn't take my word for it,
then it doesn't matter."
It's finished anyway.
It's off. It's finished.
Now, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
We'll all talk about this
in the morning
when we've had some sleep.
As far as I'm concerned,
there's nothing more to say.
May I use your phone?
I'd like to call a cab.
I'll drive you home just as
soon as I get Kay settled.
Thanks, I'd rather take a cab.
Suit yourself.
He's calling a cab.
I suppose he denied everything.
He told me his side of it.
Well, you don't
believe him, do you?
Darling, I only know
that he really loves you.
Oh, that isn't true.
He doesn't love me.
He doesn't care
whether I live or die.
Oh, I never should
have married him.
A little late
to think about that.
Uh, come on, now.
You really must get
your sleep, darling.
Come on, come on, now.
I'm gonna --
Forgive me for interrupting.
Your phone is out of order.
That's ridiculous.
Out of order?
Hello, hello, operator.
You take him home, Pops.
I can take care of myself.
Operator, op--
You're not supposed to
carry things.
You know that.
I'll take 'em up.
We don't need your help.
- Do we, Father?
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
Here, I'll take 'em,
I'll take 'em.
You don't have a room
for her down here,
some place you could
fix up as a bedroom?
There's a couch
in the living room
if she wants to try that,
find it a little hard, maybe.
You know you're not supposed to
walk up and down stairs.
Another thing,
she's supposed to drink
eight glasses of water a day.
She forgets.
So if you could remind her.
- I'll try.
- And her exercise.
Dr. Nordell wants her to walk
two to three hours each day.
An hour in the morning
and an hour in the afternoon,
and we usually take
a walk in the evening.
And she's supposed to be
in bed at 9:30.
- I'll try to remember.
- And the calcium pills.
- Did you bring your pills?
- No, I forgot.
- I'll go home and get them.
- Won't it do in the morning?
I'll give them to your father
when he takes me home.
- Now, then, your shoes.
- Buckley, really. Buckley.
You know you can't
do them yourself.
Oh, Buckley.
Buckley, what's
happening to you?
Haven't you heard?
We're having a baby.
Stanley, Stanley.
Stanley, time to get up.
Wake up, sleepyhead.
As the days went on and nothing
happened, the tension mounted.
Buckley watched Kay
as if she were a time bomb.
That's a book.
Oh!
What is it, Kay?
What's the matter?
Oh, I reneged.
I had a heart
in my hand all the time.
I don't know what
I must be thinking about.
As November came and the great
event drew nearer and nearer,
we all waited
with bated breath.
- Is that the phone?
- No, dear.
Well, I guess I'll get
a little air.
- Stanley.
- Hmm?
As long as you're going,
would you give this to Kay?
K-- Who said
anything about Kay?
I never could fool Ellie.
But I hoped I could fool Kay.
- Stanley! How are you?
- Hello, hello, hello.
- Hi, Pops.
- Hi.
Is this a beautiful night?
Did you see those stars?
Mom sent me over with this.
Oh, thanks.
Go on, go on, open it up.
Open it up. Don't mind us men.
Let me take your coat.
Oh, I can do it.
I can do it.
Well, at least let me help you.
Alright.
I'm glad you came by tonight.
She's awfully low.
- Anything wrong?
- No, no, she's just nervous.
I wish you'd talk to her.
- Oh, it's lovely.
- What is it?
It's a beautiful bed jacket.
Isn't that pretty?
Hmm. Ho-ho.
You certainly are going to knock
their eyes out at the hospital.
I'll go pack it right now.
Kay, Kay, now that your
father's here, you won't mind.
I'd like to get some cigarettes.
You don't have to
run right along, do you?
No, I can squeeze out
a couple of minutes, I guess.
I won't be long.
Hold everything till I get back.
You look wonderful, kitten.
Oh, I feel fine.
It's just Buckley.
I wish you'd talk to him.
He's so jittery.
What's he jittery about?
Oh, he -- he's afraid that,
oh, something will go wrong.
Oh.
Shouldn't feel like that.
Of course, I-I can't
tell him that, uh --
that it's going to be easy
for you.
It may not be, but...
But I do know this,
that when the time comes,
you -- you mothers seem
to have a courage
and a strength
you never knew you had.
I hope so.
As far as anything going wrong,
doctors and scientists
have been working
for hundreds of years now
so that you and your baby
can be safe.
Nothing's going to go wrong.
You know that, don't you?
I know.
Oh, Pops.
I wish it was over.
It will be soon, darling.
I'm sure that when you hold
your baby in your arms,
you'll think it was worth
anything you went through.
Aren't I silly?
Like the first day
you took me to the dentist.
Every night we put our clothes
where we could grab them
in a hurry.
We were like members
of a fire brigade
ready to jump
at the first alarm.
Well, it'll happen
almost any time now, huh?
I suppose so, sometime within
the next two or three weeks.
Two or three weeks?
I couldn't live like this
another two or three weeks.
Hello.
Sorry to wake you, but I just
brought Kay to the hospital.
Huh? No, I don't
know anything yet.
The doctor's with her now.
- We'll be right there.
Stanley, you can't do that.
You've got to really dress.
There's no telling how long
we'll be down there.
Did you remember to put
the razor in your pocket?
- The razor?
- Yes, your electric razor.
Then it doesn't matter
where you have to go to shave.
And a green shirt.
You should wake Tommy, please,
and I guess we better wire Ben.
You can phone the message in.
I must remember to tell Delilah
to fix breakfast in case
the baby's born by then.
Stanley, please hurry.
What kept you?
I'm just getting dressed.
I had to get my clothes on.
- I'll drive.
- Oh, no, no. Here, come on.
If we don't hurry,
the baby will be born
before we get there.
Come on.
The baby will be born,
and we'll never get there
if you drive.
Don't go so fast, Ellie.
We're in a business district.
Ellie, slow down a little bit.
Uh-uh! Uh...
Ellie, for heaven's sake.
I had the right of way.
Keep your eye on the road.
Your tie's on crooked.
Fix it.
Ellie, gasoline.
Come on, now, Ellie.
Pull over here. Let me drive.
- Come on.
- Stanley, be careful.
No, no, no, Ellie,
you can't make it.
There's a train.
Will you relax?
You're making me nervous.
You realize what you've done?
You've broken every
regulation in the book.
You've passed everything
on the wrong side.
You've gone through red lights.
You've exceeded the speed limit.
I know, but this
is an emergency.
For the first time in my life,
I longed for the sight
of a motorcycle cop.
Park it, will you, Stanley.
Oh, what's the matter?
What happened?
Nothing happened.
It -- It was a false alarm.
I'm sorry we brought you
all this way.
Oh, that's alright.
Nothing at all, nothing at all.
- Good night, darling.
- Good night.
- Good night, Kay.
I'm sorry.
Is that your car?
The gray one over there.
- Yes, it is.
- Is something wrong, Officer?
Yes, lady, there is.
He's parked in front
of a fire hydrant.
After a week, the strain
became too much for me.
I decided to take
a sleeping pill.
Hello?
We'll be right there.
What?
It's already here.
It's a boy.
He arrived
just half an hour ago.
Huh, okay, he's fine.
The doctor says
everything's just fine.
Yeah.
That's wonderful.
Wonderful.
Give her our love.
Ellie.
- Ellie.
- Hmm?
Remind me to tell you
something in the morning.
Will you, Ellie?
Tell me what, Stanley?
Tell me what?
Stanley, wake up.
Tell me, is it
something about Kay?
- Stanley!
- It's a boy.
Oh, Stan!
Oh, isn't that wonderful?
A boy.
I wondered if they
were crazy or was I?
He looked as old
as Methuselah to me.
All he needed was a derby.
Oh, boy!
We'll be seeing you soon.
Yes, sir.
Look at him smile.
Isn't he a darling?
- Who do you think he's like?
- He looks exactly like Kay.
- Oh.
- Like Kay?
Oh, I think you're
wrong there, Ellie.
He's a Dunstan
through and through.
- What are they gonna call it?
- It? Call him, son. Him.
I believe they're talking
about calling him Herbert.
- Aren't they?
- I believe they are.
Oh, Herbert,
isn't that wonderful?
I hope you don't mind.
I mean, since you're
the maternal grandfather, I --
Oh, no.
No, I should say. No.
Matter of fact, I think Herbert
is just the name for him.
Oh, well, I --
I admit, he looked
a little better
by the time Kay got him home.
- Perfect.
- Look at him!
Did you ever see
anything so good?
Did'ums have'um picture taken?
When is he going to
be christened?
In five or six months.
We want to wait
for Reverend Galsworthy.
Come on, Pops, you have your
picture taken with the baby.
- Oh, no, no, no, no.
- We've all had our pictures.
- No, no, not me.
- Come on, old man.
Oh, please, Pops.
Come on, just do it for me.
I want a picture
of the two of you together.
Yeah, we'll sit him right here.
How about that, my boy?
Is that alright with you?
He's smiling at you.
Hurry, Stan.
Catch him just like that.
No, no, I don't --
I just --
There we go.
Oh, no, don't give it to me.
No, no, you sit down.
Now go on,
smile at your grandfather.
- See, it's no use. I don't --
- Turn him around.
Turn him around
so we can see his face.
Come on, turn him around.
That's it. That's it.
Oh, see, it's a --
Look, look.
I-I mean, I-look --
Take him, please.
Please, take him.
Oh, what's the matter?
My goodness.
Stanley, what'd you do to him?
What do you mean?
I didn't do anything to him.
I think he's tired.
We really must go.
By the way, Stan,
I had this made up for you.
It's a photographic
record of the baby
from the day he was born.
Here, look at him here.
And then wait, wait.
Take a look at that.
And here, here.
Isn't it amazing?
Well, he changes every day.
Not to me, he doesn't.
- Coming, dearest?
- Here, put it in your pocket.
Show the boys, you know.
- Goodbye, dear.
- Good bye.
Goodbye, Stanley.
Take good care
of our "gweat bid" boy.
- Come, dear.
- Coming, darling.
How about a "gweat big" drink?
- Pops?
- Yes, dear?
- Come in. He's quiet now.
- Oh, no. Oh, no.
Now, look, Kay, it's no use.
Oh, Pops, it didn't have
anything to do with you.
It's just that, well, there were
so many other people around him.
It scared him.
Come on.
Boy, he's gonna smile.
Oh, come on in.
See, everything's alright now.
He's not scared anymore.
Is he, darling?
Now you've got a nice man here
and you're gonna give him
a big smile
'cause you're a good boy.
Now, look who's come to see you.
- Who is that, huh?
- Well.
Who is that?
Is that your grandfather?
Look.
Oh, honey, you terrible child.
What's the matter?
What happened?
Nothing, nothing, nothing.
He just took a look at me.
That's so funny.
He's such a good-tempered baby.
The doctor said
he'd never seen a baby
with such a wonderful
disposition.
Oh, I'm sure. I'm sure.
And it isn't because
you're a man.
He was smiling all over
the place at Herbert.
Pops?
Well, now, come on.
Let's blow, let's blow.
Pops?
We've come to apologize.
We want to say that we're
very sorry for being so rude.
Now, you tell him
you forgive him.
Come on, now, honey,
give him a great big smile.
Tell him how --
- Oh, you little brat.
- Oh, it's alright, darling.
He's gone now.
It's alright.
- The man is gone.
- Why do you do that?
You know what I think it is?
It's your tie.
If you just take off your tie...
No, Ellie, I'm not
going to take off my tie.
It's a perfectly nice tie,
and I happen to like it.
It was present from Tommy,
and I'm not gonna take it off
just because he doesn't like it.
Oh, Stanley, the way you talk.
He's a baby,
an innocent little baby.
He doesn't know what it is
that disturbs him.
He is not an innocent
little baby.
He's an individual with very
definite likes and dislikes.
As an individual,
I respect his right
to have likes and dislikes.
But I also reserve the right
to have a few of my own.
From that time on,
I gave him a wide berth.
It was live and let live
between us
until one weekend
six months later.
This the Banks house?
Well, yes, but, uh, wh--
Hello! Thank you.
Good evening, Mr. Banks.
See you tomorrow.
The thing I had feared
had come to pass.
He had invaded
the sanctity of my home.
Hi, Pops.
Hi, hi, Kay.
You have a visitor.
It's alright with you, Pops,
and you don't mind?
Oh, no, I'm delighted,
delighted.
He's nice, Pops.
Really is.
It's just that, well,
you two got started off
on the wrong foot, that's all.
And I thought,
well, if I left him here
for a couple of days
alone with you --
Alone?
Well, I mean,
I won't be here myself.
I'm going to Boston.
Buckley has to go there
and see Mr. Wellsford.
You know, the chain store man.
And he asked me to come.
And I said I couldn't leave the
baby, but Mom said to go ahead
and that she'd take care.
Oh, Pops, I know
you're gonna love him
just as soon as you
get to know him.
He has been a little strange.
Oh, there's my taxi.
I gotta run.
And remember this, Pops.
If he so much as
lets out a peep at you,
you have my permission
to spank him and spank him good.
- Yeah.
- Bye. Bye, Mom.
- Goodbye, goodbye, dear.
- Bye.
Stan, is that you?
Yes, it's me.
The most wonderful thing
has happened.
I thought you'd never get here.
Ah, ah, yes, Kay told me.
Oh, come up and see him.
Quick, quick.
Of course, we're not
quite organized yet.
Well, where is he?
I don't wanna step on him.
In your bureau drawer
over there.
What is that?
Well, that's my dress scarf.
Well, what are you
doing with my dress --
What?
What's going on?
Lookit here.
What are you doing with my --
- Stanley, what'd you do?
- Well, he's eating my scarf.
Oh, that's alright, dear.
It's clean.
It can't hurt him.
Can it, my darling?
Did he have to be
in that particular drawer
with all my shirts?
I took the shirts out.
They're right there.
You can put them back now.
What a love-kins.
Who's a love-kins?
Oh, Stan, it's so wonderful
having a baby in my arms again.
Who's a sweet boy?
Who's an angel?
Look at the shirts.
Who's going to sleep
in a nice big room, huh?
Is he going to sleep
in this room?
No, he's going to Tommy's room.
- Where's Tommy going?
- Into Ben's room.
I want him right here
so I can hear him if he cries.
You know, he's good, but
strange house and everything.
No Mommy or Poppy, but he's
gonna be a good boy, isn't he?
Of course he is.
I'm sorry I can't
go to the Dicksons',
but you're going anyway.
I phoned Ruth, and she's
delighted to have an extra man.
- It's all set.
- Yeah, well, I'm not going.
- Oh, now, Stanley.
- No, no, no.
I'm not going without you.
They're your friends.
Well, that's ridiculous.
You can't eat here.
There's no food in the house.
Of course, there's
last night's clam
if you don't mind
waiting on yourself.
- Where's Delilah?
- She's making up Kay's room.
Who's going to sleep
in Kay's room?
- You are.
- Now, look, look, look.
Stanley, it's the only room
in the house
where you can't possibly
hear the baby,
and I promised Kay
you wouldn't be disturbed.
Everything's ready, Miss Banks.
Oh, good, and, Delilah,
would you mind taking these
and sterilizing them?
You can use the canning pot.
You don't have to tell me.
I remember.
Mr. Banks,
isn't it just wonderful
having a baby
in the house again?
Oh, just wonderful.
Just wonderful.
Great, great.
Let's get your foot.
That's a boy.
All week I look forward
to Sunday morning.
No alarm clock,
no train to catch,
no office,
just uninterrupted slumber.
I just had to let you see him.
He's so cute.
What time is it?
6:00.
6:00?!
Well, go back to sleep, dear.
Bye.
Say, "Bye-bye."
Bye-bye.
Oh, no. Oh, no.
Sunday afternoon,
I had counted on
a good 18 holes of golf.
But Ellie thought the baby
and I should get together.
45 minutes later,
he finally corked off.
Hey, hey, hey.
Here's your ball.
Hey, wait, you tripped me!
- I didn't!
- Yes, you did!
Here, here, here, here.
Boys, boys, boys, boys.
Boys!
Stop, stop, stop. Hey!
Come on, now, let's get over
there and let's do it right.
Come on. What kind of a game
are you playing?
They were nice kids.
I was having a good time.
Look, come on.
Choose sides.
- Thanks a lot.
- Well, thank you.
You wanna watch that dribble,
get that...
It was a good game.
I was wondering whether or not
to tell Ellie about it.
She'd probably think
I was crazy
playing ball with
a lot of kids.
Where do you think
you're going with it?
I'm -- I'm sorry.
I suddenly thought maybe
Ellie came and got him.
I didn't take the train.
I flew.
I got so homesick for the baby.
Where is the baby?
Shouldn't he be home by now?
Don't you worry.
He's with your father,
so he's alright.
You should see your father..
Hey!
Police station.
Hurry up.
Hello, hello?
Is anybody here?
Anybody here?
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Officer, Officer, has anybody
turned in a baby here?
I've lost a baby.
Is it your baby?
Oh, no, no, no, no,
it's my daughter's baby.
- It's my grandson.
- Where'd you lose him?
I-I lost him in the park.
He was in the park
in his carriage.
I left him for a second.
When I came back he was gone
and the carriage was gone.
You say you only left him
for a second, eh?
Well, maybe a minute.
I don't know, five minutes.
You know,
some kids were playing soccer.
And I went to watch them,
got kind of interested.
And you forgot your grandchild.
Well, I guess I did
for the minute.
That's fine.
That's wonderful.
They give you a child to mind,
and you run off and forget him.
What's the matter, Jack?
You losing your marbles?
Now, wait a minute.
This kind of talk is --
Do you -- Did you
understand what I said?
A baby has been lost.
A little baby has --
Why don't you do what
you're supposed to do?
Do something.
Get on the television.
Tell the typer, whatever you do.
Describe the baby.
He's five months --
six months old.
Wearing a little white --
You know what babies wear.
He's got -- got on
a little cap, I think.
Would you know what
color his eyes are?
Brown. Brown. Brown. Blue.
I-I don't know.
But you are sure it's a boy.
I don't blame you.
You haven't said anything to me
I haven't said to myself.
My daughter's home now
waiting for the baby.
I don't know what to do.
I'm going crazy.
I'll -- I'll do anything.
Look, I'll have a big reward,
whatever, whatever I have to do
if you'll just help me.
Well, it just so happens
we picked up your baby.
Oh, thank God.
But it wasn't any five minutes
you were gone.
It was nearer a half an hour.
Yes, sir.
- Where is he? In here?
- Yeah.
Just a minute.
What's your daughter's
phone number?
I'm gonna call her up and check.
Oh, no, don't do that.
Don't, please.
Please don't do it.
Don't do it. You don't know.
I couldn't stand it.
I couldn't face my daughter.
Please, I promise you, I'll do
anything if you give me the kid.
I'll take him right home.
I won't stop anywhere.
I promise you.
Well, I'll talk it over
with the boys.
They've taken quite
a fancy to this kid.
If they get any idea
you weren't treating him right,
you'd never get
out of here alive.
Alright, boys,
they've come for him.
I dreaded the moment
when he'd see me.
I knew if he started to cry,
I was cooked.
I said a little prayer, "Don't
let him cry just this once.
Don't let him cry."
Come on, son, we're going home.
Come on! Whoa!
Well, that's my boy.
That's my boy.
From that time on,
I was his pigeon.
Yes, yes!
The day of the baby's
christening came at last.
He was the center
of a little world.
His grandparents, his parents,
and his godparents,
all of us gathered together
for the solemn occasion.
I couldn't help feeling
we were ganging up on him,
pinning the name of Herbert
on a poor, defenseless child.
"Suffer the little children
to come unto me
and forbid them not.
For of such is
the kingdom of God."
Funny how I had resented
the very idea of him
when Kay first told us.
I was furious at both of them.
Making me grandfather.
It seemed to spell
the end of my life.
Now I couldn't imagine
life without him.
...our heavenly Father
now and forever more.
Amen.
We were coming
to his big moment.
We all watched him
with bated breath.
How would he behave
when the Reverend Galsworthy
took him in his arms?
Would he be terrified?
Would he cry?
Not that baby.
To him the Reverend Galsworthy
was just another face
to be explored.
Name this child.
Stanley Banks.
Stanley Banks,
I baptize thee in the name
of the Father,
the Son, and the Holy Ghost.
Amen.
We receive this child in the
congregation of Christ's flock.
And do sign him
with the sign of...
Stanley Banks, my grandchild.
My first grandchild.